hey guys I've commandeered Chris's
channel for today I hope you guys enjoy
my little Valentine's Day special well
let's hope Chris doesn't find out I'm
doing this enjoy okay guys back letting
you know giving you a nice feminine list
of things to watch her around times
daddy I'm in the kitchen and this
sandwich ain't making itself where are
you what the heck is this what have you
done to my wall did you kind of forget
what day it is
you put a heart on the bat symbol what
is this crap well I'm kind of torturing
you for Verdean it's Valentine's Day
well I guess since we're here might as
well do something this is my girlfriend
by the way girlfriend she's my fiancee
yeah what are we doing here what have
you done what is this for seriously you
kind of forget what day it is it's
Valentine's Day right congratulations
you remembered by the way do you get
anything for me yes uh-huh sure okay
I guess since you forgot we'll just have
to do something a little different
though you are buying dinner tonight by
the way
well I was gonna talk about romance
movies to watch for Valentine's Day and
give them a little bit of a play-by-play
on what to walked with your girlfriend
for Valentine's Day
romance movies what is it why like what
kind of romance movies what are we
talking about here I personally have a
preference for Azzaro
those kind of romance movies romance
movies that aren't romance movies you
know what it just so happens that I
actually read your mind and I have some
pics of my own so let's start talking
about them I actually really love
maskers
I think it's a good movie it's directed
by Martin Campbell it was one of those
movies to me where it could easily go
both ways like it could have been
horrible and really cheesy and over the
top and this silly had that really good
adventure spirit kind of like Indiana
Jones but without copying off of it and
usually most romance movies the guys are
hot they're just pretty mediocre
lukewarm that's what I always say I
should be in more romance movies yes sir
because you were definitely lukewarm
Thanks
what am i here it means in this film is
when he's life is open her dress of
course you know I like that scene as
well I like it because that's a good
pick on I actually really agree with
that because mask Azhar is a really fun
movie but it's a good movie that you can
actually watch men and women can enjoy
it it's not just like your typical
romance adventurous thing the sequel
we're not gonna talk about the sequel
but the first one pretty good movie
we're gonna talk about my first pick
which is 500 days of summer now you
might look at this movie and say Chris
that that's a romance movie for sure the
reason this is on my list is because
it's actually a fairly realistic
portrayal of a romance it's not overly
fluffy it's not Hollywood eyes if you've
seen the movie I don't want to spoil
anything for you it doesn't go the way
most of these romances do it's a really
realistic portrayal of the way a guy may
approach a romance sometimes he was
actually the first independent movie I
went to theaters to see like I suck I
seeked it out I went really far away to
see it
it's peaked out a word I sought it out
see that's why she's here I happen to
actually even joy this movie as well I
do like Zoey she is pretty good and
almost everything she does will not
mention a couple of her yeah so good
movies I actually enjoyed a lot of the
artistic detailing to put into the film
a lot of the backgrounds are really
pretty and well thought out can't say
that I didn't not mind the clothes in it
either
enjoy this island Joseph gordon-levitt
looks good in the best okay
that's what I always say more cushion
for the push
Shh in there one what was that implying
nothing
what's your shirt yes what's your next
pick hun okay going to my Kiki Kiki Kiki
side we all love that Howl's Moving
Castle really good movie hi amazake
wonderful wonderful director if you guys
haven't seen anything by him
except for maybe Ponyo which is one of
his most recent releases in thing now
one of his best films but a little bit
more kid like a little more less
whimsical than his normal films I'd
enjoyed this though this is actually
based on one of my favorite books and I
thought I did the book justice which
concern I'm an avid reader for me is a
very high compliment
I am very picky about how books aren't
read on into movies art styling the
classic details his hiya Miyazaki's
artwork is just so gorgeous there this
whole film and the plot and the
characters voicings in the English
downed Elise is so perfect
it's just they did such an amazing job
the music I love the score throughout
this you don't even like realize it's
gonna be a romance until it's like
halfway into the tilma to have that
feeling that it's an actual romance it's
very classic in certain aspects it's
totally different as all of his movies
are but like the first time you do see
how he literally sweeps her office for
her feet like he literally comes and
goes and like sweeps her up than
everything but it was just the way the
film was told the incredible animation I
mean the animation for that man I
watched it very recently for the first
time actually I hadn't seen it I love
anime she enjoys anime the thing about
this video is we want to talk to you
about movies that you can maybe watch
with your nerdy or geeky boyfriend or
girlfriend and actually enjoy them and
not be all like lovefest lovey dovey
plus you don't have to be a geek to
enjoy them know everybody can like sit
down and enjoy this because it's just a
well-written film and there's plenty of
action plenty of to go on in this movie
I agree all right guys so my next pick
is a movie that I actually what was that
just okay my next pick is a movie that I
mercifully did not show you because it's
a very good movie it's a very very good
movie but it's just one of those movies
where when you watch it you're like like
it's just it's very depressing the
movies Blue Valentine now this is
technically another romance movie but
it's not because it's actually about the
degrading of them
the marriage falling apart and you watch
it happen and it's definitely not a date
movie that's a hundred percent shirt you
do not like I went to Walmart and it had
the Valentine's Day section and Blue
Valentine was in it I was like trust me
you're not gonna get any action after
Blue Valentine if you watch that with
your date it is a great movie though the
performances in it
are you very interested in the back
cover are you just staring at Ryan
Gosling that's what I thought the thing
I love about this movie was the
performances Ryan Gosling and Michelle
Williams are so good in this movie and
so realistic and there really is nothing
about the performances that seem set up
it's also well told if you love romance
movies this is nothing like any of the
others 100% but just beware if you watch
it with your date there will not be a
make-out session afterwards trust me
100% no unless you're trying to well
trying to and the relationship yeah try
to end the relationship and make a mess
of your apartment one thing you can do
with Valentine let's say you're in a
relationship you don't want to be in
anymore just like a great can we watch
Blue Valentine honey another one based
on a book you guys have probably seen it
a hundred million times we're gonna go
with Casino Royale that's right and I
have the bond 50 blu-ray collection here
it'd be nice if I could just have our
whole Casino Royale but trust me it's in
there I have to say I don't like the
first version a Casino Royale I actually
like the version with Daniel Craig just
to specify mean Peter Sellers that one
wasn't so hot the sixties one yeah no
this one's completely different yeah I'm
a little bit different
love the newer version that's a I know
Craig looks smoking hot nut oh yes he
does I love his eyes I have blue eyes
thanks the thing about Casino Royale
that I love is not only just the way it
was directed but also by Martin Campbell
like your first thick mask of zorro the
way the film was crafted to be able to
reintroduce bond to us trust me with Die
Another Day in Pierce Brosnan's last few
movies we had gone in a bad note that
just like ruined my love of bond does
last
this was like oh please listen II won be
good please have beggin you otherwise I
will be turned off a bond for the rest
of my life and it was it was awesome and
the action is incredible in the film
Daniel Craig is great in it the opening
theme is really good by Chris Cornell
but also the romance in the film is one
of the only true romances in bond
because most of the films are just he
has throwaway relationships he doesn't
care about right I mean that's it that's
the thing because at the end of the
movie if you've seen the film spoilers
alert just let you know at the end of
the movie when he walks up to the guy
and he just goes I'm James Bond that's
when he becomes Mons the first time you
hear the Bond theme afterwards so this
movie is really kind of like the Batman
Begins for mond yeah you know but the
romance in the film was so well told
because it kind of gets you to
understand why Bond became a womanizer
exactly because wow this woman really
wronged him and now he doesn't like
women anymore he's gonna treat them like
they're disposable kind of depressing
ending for her it was for her it was but
I mean she deserved it you think no she
was trying to save her that's true
see the thing about this movie is it's
not just like cut and dry like she did
try to save bond because you find out
that she kept him from being killed when
he was being tortured yeah made a deal
to say no to me twisting turns trying to
follow it unless you're actually paying
attention kind of iffy throughout the
whole thing and then there's just so
many like little quirky things that if
you pay attention to one scene you'll
catch it again later and it's just like
I had to say though her makeup in
certain spots looked so much better than
the other spots like she was wearing too
much makeup in a couple scenes so any
girl who likes particularly picking
apart women's features that are prettier
than them that's one thing you can
critique on her is overdone makeup you
know what I don't get too much into
looking at makeup but I actually kind of
agree she looked better in the movie
when she wasn't wearing makeup I really
agree but nevertheless great Bond films
still actually my favorite even though I
really like Skyfall which you make up we
did talk about makeup you have to see
Skyfall though yeah I know I admit I
haven't seen the Skyfall yet when it
came out I didn't have the chance to go
and see it which kind of was a little
depressing I bought it
together I guess that's what we did it
for you're still buying dinner go okay
well very good pick with bond when my
favorite movies definitely my next pick
is also a film that is more
action-oriented like Casino Royale was
but it's a film that has a center of
romance that you don't really start to
notice until the film continues on
towards the end and that's the first
matrix now the romance elements of
reloaded in revolutions they went way
more towards the actual romance with a
really crappy sex scene and everything
but this film I thought it was done
really well because the whole they they
interlocked the whole thing with how neo
couldn't become the one until Trinity
admitted that she loved him obviously
the matrix was revolutionary is an
action film and the reason I want to
include on this list matrix really was
revolutionary in my childhood it came
out in 99 age where it's just like oh my
god we're actually loved watch more
mature films yeah exactly because I was
like 12 then and then there I was
started woman okay grabs what are you
saying thanks thank you very much
nevertheless the matrix of the film that
really inspired me as a kid I went out
with my friends and made a whole bunch
of short films together you've seen some
of the crappy Matrix movies are made
when I was a kid and but they're great
though you're not yes they are in that
sense you know where it's like nostalgia
nostalgic childhood exactly they're
terrible though they're awful they
really are they came towards me at that
point where I was interpretation because
of this film yeah and the reason the
matrix inspired me so much as a kid was
not just because of the visual look and
feel of it but the story was really
interesting too and whenever you have
like a big adventure like this there's
generally a central romance of some kind
whether it's Han and Leia and star wars
sir Indiana Jones and Marion it's the
way they usually later a film yes
there's the usual staging of a little
bit of the romance a little bit of the
action and the reason this movie works
is because they were able to balance all
those elements so well and in the end it
actually actually made the movie because
sometimes it's downtime just explains so
much more of the uptime a high B energy
a couple of the scenes had they were
trying to survive in such harsh climates
and trying to live a normal life still
kind of and fall in love and that type
of situation is very admirable of course
it's so romantic
and anyway the matrix is definitely a
good movie for us nerdiest people to
watch if you are into that sort of thing
st. if not really but you know what
nerds have like the big coke bottle
glasses the pocket protector and you
subscribe me as youth
no I you're a nerd okay my next pick is
The Dark Knight Rises because I am a
die-hard Catwoman fan I just like that
she's talking about the Dark Knight
Rises and everyone just understood why
we're dating because you said The Dark
Knight Rises in an admirable sense there
are a couple films could you disagree
upon though there's a few yeah we're not
gonna talk about them though Dark Knight
Rises
alright Dark Knight Rises gotta say I
love Catwoman and I love Batman first
movie I ever actually remember watching
in the theater was at a drive-in
watching one of the old 1990s Batman
with the penguin well Batman Returns Oh
penguin in the riddler no really
returned a double feature Oh hmm that's
interesting it was a special for the
night cuz a new one had just came out oh
so you saw Batman Forever and then they
shot Batman Returns okay cool that's
kind of cool actually except for Batman
Forever unfortunately you had to watch
that I was young it was still good then
that's true I loved that movie as a kid
it was a good film as a kid admit that
when I was a kid I thought that I even
thought Batman and Robin was cool I was
when I when I was like 10 years old I
was like who's look at all the sparkly
lights yeah yep and then you go back and
watch all the vintage Batman episodes
and you're just like wow I love this guy
he's so awesome when you're kid and then
you've watch it now that you're an adult
and just like how did they make this
what was entertainment value this some
days you just can't get rid of a bomb
kapow punch yeah again with dart
tetrises it's a movie where the romance
kind of sneaks up on you it's hinted at
constantly throughout the film and you
know if you know anything about that man
you know Batman
woman had a thing many times throughout
the comments this film did it so well
because you could so easily be so cheesy
and over-the-top with these two people
in the costumes making out and
everything but they handle it so well
because in Batman Returns it was a
little over-the-top of Catwoman on top
of him like licking which was a nice
view but you know it just kind of got a
little silly most of the way for this
film you don't think it's gonna end the
way it dies until you get to that and
we're just like oh my god she's not
actually who she says she is so you kind
of think Bruce is gonna end up with a
different person yeah I mean there's
like these hints with the Miranda Tate
character and everything and then it
just kind of gets you get the rug pulled
out under you and some people were not
fans of that plot but I enjoyed it and I
thought it was well handled I agree I'm
going the direct route into things but
then it kind of if you've read the
comics like I did as a kid you kind of
realized Marin Tate was going to be
yeah Talia Ra's al Ghul's daughter right
okay now my next pick is another film
that I have not yet shown you simply
because he's scared of my reaction
exactly I am I'm afraid she just be like
I don't like this movie Chris and then
I'll be like I'll cry in the corner
that's Drive and you guys know that I
just drive is a special movie for me
it's the I Ryan Gosling's heads right
there don't look at him too long
otherwise you'll break up because I'm
not as attractive as him the reason I
have drive on this list is because it's
another film that both the man and woman
could potentially enjoy if the woman
doesn't mind some graphic violence but
the thing about this movie is obviously
the directorial style which I maybe one
day will trust you to watch I just
thought I'm so afraid if I put it in
your gonna be like yeah was that one
movie that we're not going to talk about
that I can't believe you didn't like and
I'm just like holy crap how did not like
that movie but you didn't it's fine it's
fine
but at the heart of it the reason the
movie works is because of the central
romance between Ryan Gosling's character
and Carrie Mulligan's character they
have a love for each other that cannot
be spoken about because she's married
and he has a kind of hard time with the
life that he is living he's got this
really what are you doing what why is
there a bear on me just what the movie
central romance works because of the way
it's told and
one day I'll show it to you I think but
the movie just had this feel to it where
you really actually felt that he was in
love with this girl and he barely ever
acknowledges that vocally you can just
feel it in the air when they're in the
room together obviously it's one of my
favorite movies for other reasons than
that but if you're into a movie that you
can watch with your date and you both
don't mind watching a movie like drive
check it out alright guys in my final
pick for today is classic French film
Amelie this is a very artsy film that
has wonderful music scores wonderful
shots this whole film is done in certain
color palettes that you just see it
through the whole film mm-hmm it's so
pretty to watch and like then you get
into the characters and you're just like
you fall in love with her as you watch
her go along and you fall in love with a
little slightly handicapped guy with the
one-armed you don't realize doesn't have
one arm so part of the way through when
you realize his sleeve is kind of
hanging a little weird and then there's
the guy with the brittle bones you just
like feel very sorry for that you can't
leave his apartment and then there's the
slight edginess of the who works in
the bar with her a in a bar maybe
not in really a shock
I liked Amelie - she showed it to me
recently and I know it's it's one of the
most famous foreign films made it has a
definite cult following a lot of people
really followed that movie and like even
where we live in Cleveland there was a
showing of it recently at a theater and
there was all these people that dressing
up like characters and stuff and it's
definitely an interesting movie but the
reason it's not necessarily your
stereotypical romance movie is because
of the way that romance is handled in
the film the lead actress of the movie
is very reclusive she doesn't approach
it the way that most movies handle
romances like the way she goes about
trying to get him to notice her and
everything I found really unique and
different and just not like your
stereotypical fluffy romance you know
Nicholas Sparks movie yeah garden gnome
gotta love garden over here I got this
whole thing there's a running gag with
the garden gnome that's like you don't
realize it it's like a central point of
this kind of thing with her father which
plays back to her beginning child which
is kind of how she developed into the
person she is and you kind of get a
little blurb and feeling of it
throughout the whole film about kind of
like who she is as a person and a little
bit of her more quirky side and
gonna go with quirky as the word for her
so if you guys are into foreign films if
you don't mind watching a movie with
subtitles it is definitely one of the
better foreign films out there it looks
incredible the movie looks beautiful and
as she said the color palette for the
movie is really impressive so with my
final pick I'm actually gonna break the
rules a little bit because we've been
talking about movies but this is just
something that I had to talk about it
actually there are two movies based off
of this television show a lot of times
you guys asked me hey Chris where your
TV reviews when I do more television
reviews it's just I just don't always
have the time for that but one of my
favorite television shows if not my
favorite is the x-files and the x-files
has one of the most well developed
romances in TV ever I mean they don't
even do anything for like the first
seven seasons at all like they just
they're just constant romantic tension
between these two characters that's
developed along the show I'm currently
watching through it again right now what
are you what are you wincing at laugh at
what Howl's Moving Castle Howl's Moving
Castle X Files X Files an excellent show
x5 yes it's an excellent show but I
didn't laugh at your house when in
castle did I laugh at hi a Miyazaki how
would you laugh at x-files
it's hex files how come you're not laugh
at x-files the whole thing is basically
funny we're gonna talk about this later
no I wanted to talk about that show
because it definitely meant a lot to me
as a child and it's one of the reasons
that I got into the idea of filmmaking
the x-files for sure is because I was
inspired by that show I've always liked
more supernatural paranormal like alien
like stuff and I've always kind of
gotten into the idea of making a scary
movie because of the x-files I can see
you making faces by the way the show
inspired me a lot as a kid and it was
something that continued to inspire me
as an adult when I grew up and I loved
that show but it also has a great sense
of romance and it definitely has romance
elements without being a romance well
thanks for watching this video guys I
really appreciate it it was sort of her
idea to start with it was a good idea
alright guys thanks for joining us that
sounded really really really bad by the
way it did alright guys thanks for
tuning in and watching him and me well
hopefully get to see a little bit more
of me maybe I don't know maybe I might
commandeer the channel I always do have
access to his camera and the internet
news account no they don't have that
that's not gonna happen I'm gonna come
in here one day all my videos are gonna
be gone they're gonna replace with like
this and we're done thanks a lot for
watching guys I appreciate you watching
our video as always guys thanks a lot
for watching and if you want to you can
click right here and get yes you are
alright guys gets documen i've
[Music]